ارتفع عدد الوفيات الناجمة عن فيروس كورونا في جميع أنحاء العالم
الآن إلى أكثر من 1000 شخص ، حيث
تجاوزوا إجمالي الوفيات الناجمة عن فيروس السارس
الذي ظهر منذ ما يقرب من عقدين من الزمن ،
دعونا نحضر كبير مراسلينا الطبيين
د.  سانجاي جوبتا
سانجاي حقيقة أن هناك الآن
وفيات أكثر من سارس ،
ما الذي يخبرنا به ذلك عن المكان الذي
يتجه إليه هذا الفيروس ، نعم ، أعني أن هذا من
الواضح أنه خبر مخيب للآمال ولكن ليس من
المستغرب تمامًا أننا كنا
نشاهد هذه الأرقام تتزايد  بالتأكيد
خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ، أعتقد أن
ما يخبرنا به هو أن
هذا الفيروس سهل الانتشار أكثر بكثير
مقارنة بالسارس ،
فقد زاد عدد الوفيات
أيضًا ولكن عدد الحالات
زاد  أكثر بكثير من عدد
الوفيات مقارنة بالسارس ، لذا ما
لديك هو أنه يمكنك إلقاء نظرة على
الأرقام التي تحتوي على 40.000 بالإضافة إلى
العدوى وأعتقد أنها تقترب من ألف
حالة وفاة الآن ولكنها في الحقيقة
نسبة هذين الرقمين  أنه
يجب عليك الانتباه إلى الوفيات
الناجمة عن العدوى على اليسار مع السارس ، فهي
تقترب من 10 ٪ مع هذا أقرب إلى
اثنين ونصف في المائة وشيء واحد
ذئب وأنا أعلم أنك سمعت هذا أيضًا
لكن الباحثين في هونغ كونغ يقولون إنه يمكن أن يكون هناك عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص المصابين أكثر من هؤلاء الـ 40.000 شخص وقد يبدو هذا مخيبًا للآمال ولكن الحقيقة هي أنه إذا كان الأشخاص الآخرون المصابون لا يظهرون أي أعراض أو يكون الحد الأدنى منها فقط. الأعراض التي من شأنها أن تخفض نسبة الوفيات هذه أكثر مما يركز عليه مسؤول الصحة العامة أكثر شيئين ، اسمحوا لي أن أريكم هذا المربع إذا نظرت إلى المحور السيني هناك ، فهذه هي مدى خطورة هذا الفيروس والنتيجة النهائية المحور y هو مدى قابلية انتقال ما تريد لتجنب ما تأمل ألا يحدث هو أن ينتهي هذا الأمر في المربع D حيث يكون قابلاً للانتقال بدرجة عالية وقاتل للغاية في الوقت الحالي ، ولحسن الحظ ، يبدو أن فيروس الهالة الجديد هذا يبدو أكثر في المربع. نطاق واسع ما زلنا لا نعرف بالضبط مدى انتشار هذا المرض ولا نعرف مدى خطورة ذلك ، لكن يبدو أن هذا قد ينتهي به الأمر إلى الشعور بأنك أكثر نزلة برد أو إنفلونزا مقابل جائحة مميت.  تنتشر
هذه الأسئلة في جميع أنحاء العالم ، وهي أسئلة لا تزال
بحاجة إلى إجابة شيء آخر
أريد فقط أن أشير إلى الكثير من
النقاش حول هذه الأقنعة وأنواع أخرى
من معدات الحماية الشخصية ،
فقد زاد الطلب على هذه الأنواع من الأقنعة
مائة مرة  ارتفع السعر
عشرين مرة خارج
إعدادات الرعاية الصحية خارج تلك
المقاطعة في الصين ، ربما لا يكون هناك
دور حقيقي لهذه الأقنعة ، أعني إذا
نظرت إليها ربما لن
تفاجأ بمعرفة أن الجزيئات الفيروسية
يمكن أن تمر عبر  الأقنعة
التي يمكن أن تلتف حول الحواف بالتأكيد
لن تقدم الكثير من الفوائد في معظمها ، فقد يكون
تذكيرًا بتجنب الأشخاص المرضى
أو عدم لمس أنفك أو فمك
ولكن أفضل نصيحة هي  لفعل نفس
الأشياء التي كنت ستفعلها لتجنب الإنفلونزا ،
ابتعد عن المرضى ، اغسل
يديك قدر الإمكان ولا تلمس
وجهك بقدر ما تستطيع كذلك
، حسنًا ، تناول
الطعام جيدًا هناك.
الجميع قلقون من أن قضاء 14 يومًا في أماكن صغيرة أمر صعب للغاية ، لذلك نحتاج إلى رعاية الأشخاص خاصة أولئك الذين يعانون من ظروف موجودة مسبقًا وكبار السن ، فنحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا لنكون مستعدين ونختبر أولئك الذين هم أكثر عرضة للخطر أولاً ثم قم بإحضارهم إلى منشآت خاصة إذا كانت نتيجة اختبارهم إيجابية حتى لا يصلوا إلى هناك ، كيف كان هذا الأمر صعبًا بالنسبة لحكومتك لمحاولة التعامل مع مشكلة ليست من صنعك وليس فقط عندما لا تعرف Quino kuranda اليوم القمري الذي تحمل فيه هذه السفينة العديد من الجنسيات على لورد ، لذا فهي مشكلة تتعلق بالعديد من البلدان التي يطلبون جميعًا مساعدتنا لذلك علينا أن نتحمل المسؤولية عن هذا هدفنا الأساسي هو منع حدوث جائحة في بلدنا ولكن في نفس الوقت نريد أن يعود كل شخص على متن المركب بأمان حتى لا تستطيع اليابان القيام بذلك بمفردها ، فنحن بحاجة إلى الكثير من التعاون من البلدان الأخرى ، حسنًا ، الحيوانات أيضًا في الخطوط الأمامية لهذا الفيروس ، تقول مجموعات الإنقاذ أن الآلاف من الحيوانات الأليفة في حالة جيدة.  تقطعت بهم السبل في ووهان
ونفد الطعام والماء لأن
أصحابها لا يستطيعون العودة إلى ديارهم
، يتم استدعاء المتطوعين
لاقتحام المنازل لتجديد الإمدادات
للحيوانات التي يقولون
إنه تم العثور على بعضها بالقرب من المجاعة.
لأكثر من
أسبوعين والعديد من أصحاب الحيوانات الأليفة الذين غادروا
لقضاء عطلة رأس السنة القمرية الجديدة
لم يخططوا للبقاء بعيدًا لفترة طويلة